that's what you need to know and
completely unrelated the quarterback's
number 10 and number 9 completely and
totally unrelated Patriots quarterback
Tom Brady working out with Josh Gorton
video posted recently on social media
and it got Patriots fans very excited
does this mean Josh Gordon is gonna be
reinstated what does this mean what is
the message what is the the import of
this I mean here's the bottom line Josh
Gordon is still a member of the Patriots
he's under contract with the Patriots
the question is when will the league let
him play again Jeff how's the athletic
reached out to the league for comment on
whether or not there's a timeline for a
decision on a possible reinstatement or
reinstatement or riri reinstatement of
Josh Gordon but here's the one thing
I've noticed in recent years Chris I
feel like the NFL is going easier on
guys who are caught in the gears of the
substance abuse policy they don't like
taking great players off the field and
they give them extra chances whether
it's Josh Gordon martavis Bryant the
Raiders receiver or Randy Gregory two
Cowboys defensive end I think all three
of those guys had multiple potential
violations and a treatment plan right or
the substance abuse policy but they let
them hang around and they took some time
before booting them out they're supposed
to boot them out for one strike after
they've been reinstated following a
suspension of more than a year so I feel
like there's some lenience there I which
makes me think right maybe they're gonna
find a way to let Josh Gordon get back
in before the start of the season yeah I
don't know if it happens before the
season and I don't know what you know of
course New England would like him back
to the start of the season but you know
New England - they're not gonna panic if
he's not you know able to play and still
suspended maybe first four weeks six
weeks eight weeks I think the goal New
England has in mind as always as you and
I talked about you know it's playoffs
and they want Josh Gordon to be ready
for that time in the year and they're
gonna you know still have Brady and
people keep in contact with him to make
sure he's ready to contribute when that
time does come Gordon he played a
significant role for that team last year
and really helped them out in some key
moments and some moments where they were
banged up a wide receiver he was crucial
there so it seems to be a happy marriage
there and yeah it's just about when it
happens but I'm with you Mike it does
seem like the NFL has been a little more
humane towards this and realizing that
these aren't necessarily
just bad people that this is a real
struggle and some people really do you
know have issues with the disease of
addiction and I'm glad to see that the
NFL is being a little more lenient with
some of this stuff and a lot of this
behavior happens on your own time I'd
say all of it happens I mean I've yet to
see a guy get suspended for actually
smoking marijuana or doing some other
non PE drug at routine facility right
yeah so it's on your own time yeah a lot
of times during the offseason and and
they reach into the private lives of
players and they police the private
lives of players and that may have been
okay thirty years ago when the war on
drugs was happening but nowadays with
thirty four states I believe allowing
marijuana use for medical purposes and
some number less than that for
recreational purposes that the pendulum
has swung it's a different vibe it's a
different time but the other side of
this to the NFL doesn't want to come out
and say we're being lenient because they
have the power under the substance abuse
policy and they don't want to give it up
right so it's a tough spot for them
because if it looks like you're going
soft then then there's no reason for the
NFLPA to try to negotiate with the NFL
make a concession to get them to soften
the policy but I think their league
realizes it's in their own best
interests right that let great players
play do not get hung up on things that
have no relevance whatsoever to what a
guy can do on a football field yeah with
you a hundred percent Mike yeah and you
know and then hey let's just make an
examples of anybody else working in the
the business world there's plenty of
people I know who work on Wall Street
and they got addiction problems okay and
they're still working there their bosses
don't know and they still do a great job
but this is something they have to
battle whether it's you know they're
alcoholics or something bitter pill
poppers whatever it may be so this goes
on in normal life and why should a you
know I always just go watching a
football players life and career and
future all be ruined
you know by something that I don't know
necessarily impacts everything you do on
the field or in your business and let me
just make one last point because there
are certain lines of work where safety
concerns Manatee that's right if you're
flying a plane if you're driving a bus
if you're running clean right but
there's never been a suggestion that
this is a safety issue in the NFL
no one is ever
said well we can't have a guy out there
on a football field who you know is
disoriented or high or whatever because
football is the ultimate meritocracy if
you can't play you're not on the field
that's right if they can tell you're not
getting it done they got somebody else
they can put in the game hey what's
wrong with Johnson I don't know get him
out of the get him out of the game
they're not gonna drug test and they
just know he stinks that day that's
right if you're good if you're good
enough that you're still a great player
even if you've got THC in your system
then so be it again it's the ultimate
meritocracy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports